okay
cuomo you know what's next if he doesn't
resign let's talk about cuomo if cuomo
doesn't resign you know the whole story
came out yesterday so well first of all
he florida with me he touched my face
hot dog he told me to eat the whole
sausage he told me to do this he told me
to do that with
daughter sitting right next to him
yesterday's story comes he put his hand
under my blouse and he groped my breasts
right another story that comes up okay
you know what's next
you know what's next here's what's next
if cuomo doesn't resign they have 20
other stories
they're just sprinkling it they're not
putting all of it out slowly and they're
telling cool
listen do you not think a call behind
closed doors is happening and the call
goes something like this with the people
who have the real power
not cuomo here's what the call sounds
like um
andrew it's time there is no way in the
world my dad would would be
to grave turn i would never resign do
you know what this means to my family's
legacy
i would discipli i get it andrew but we
have 10 more stories
and we have the story you don't want us
to talk about
so each week we're gonna put a new story
until you finally resign we're telling
you resign
now i'm not gonna do it okay watch the
news tomorrow
news story coming out enjoy your
thursday you wake up
a woman comes out another one you know
saying that
he's like oh [ __ ] okay hey uh andrew
yeah so are you ready to resign
no way you're not gonna bully me i'm a
new yorker you're not gonna do me my
italian descent
okay another story is going to come out
monday
i can tell you stories are going to come
out until this guy resigns and by the
way it's not republicans doing it
it's democrats doing it to him i talked
to ron kim new york state assemblyman
who is part of the whole
aoc camp and bernie sanders camp cannot
stand cuomo
okay for what he did with the old folks
nursing homes is what he did and kim is
not crazy these are not crazy these are
mainstream democrats these
are level-headed people they're not
freaks i'm talking to ron
ron you know listen don't get me wrong
he's a socialist proud he's a guy that's
progressive
yes he's a guy that's on that side but
behind closed doors
he's getting pushed out non-stop he is
eventually going to get pushed out
non-stop if he if he doesn't resign
expect a story to come out
every single week that's my prediction i
may be wrong but i think behind closed
doors there's 20 other stories that are
waiting to come out
one once every week until the guy
finally says you know how it's going to
happen here's how it's going to happen
um mom's going to call chris is going to
call
and they're going to say look bro i'm
just telling you
i'm telling you right now it's time
just do it bro i don't care i'm gonna
back you up but you go out there and do
it
okay forget about it we've had a great
life we've done well for ourselves
these guys are now trashing our family
daughter doesn't know my niece doesn't
need to hear this
it's time and he's going to say what are
you talking about dad mario would have
said
i get it but this is a very unique
situation it's enough
we got to do it and i still have your
back i think that's what it could lead
to i hope it doesn't but i think that's
what it's going to lead to
where he's going to have to resign so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
you